billy eilish says she's sorry after a
video resurfaced of the singer mouthing
a derogatory term used against members
of the asian community
the 19 year old grammy winner shared
this lengthy statement on her instagram
story
monday explaining that she was around 13
or 14 years old when she mouthed a word
from tyler the creator's song
fish that at the time she says she
didn't know was an offensive anti-asian
slur
the grammy winner wrote in part quote i
am appalled and
embarrassed and want to barf that i ever
mouthed along to that word
billy then addressed a second clip which
shows her quote
speaking in a silly gibberish made-up
voice
which she says is something she has done
her entire life when speaking to her
pets
friends and family in response to claims
that she was both speaking in a black
and
asian accent the oceanized singer said
it was quote in no way
an imitation of anyone or any language
accent
or culture quote regardless of how it
was interpreted
i did not mean for any of my actions to
have caused hurt to others
and it absolutely breaks my heart that
it is being labeled now in a way that
might cause pain to people hearing it
billy maintains that she has always used
her platform
quote to fight for inclusion kindness
tolerance equity and equality that's all
i'd say to be honest with you
and she concluded her lengthy apology by
encouraging people to quote
continue having conversations listening
and
learning before telling her fans that
she hears them and she loves them
the super fans who like i love to my
core
billy's apology comes after she received
online backlash for the resurfaced clips
with many calling to boycott the
singer-songwriter
but prior to the controversy billy was
having a pretty good year which is so
incredible and it was so amazing in
february she released her documentary
film
the world's a little blurry on apple tv
plus
every 17 year old's 17th year is
quite a ride and um but this one
involved um
you know emerging as the voice of a
generation if not the voice of
of our time and um and and
the the the burdens responsibilities
privileges opportunities
that go along with that but there's also
you know the story of a very real girl
in her 17th year in march she took home
two grammys
she also changed up her signature look
appeared on the cover of vogue
and in june she dropped her new track
lost cause off her upcoming sophomore
album happier than ever
along with the accompanying
self-directed music video
something's in the air right now like
i'm losing track of time
like i don't really care right now
but maybe that's fine